[Music]
our method of the year for 2011 is
genome editing with engineered nucleases
this is a technology that lets
researchers pick just about any spot in
the genome in many species and put in
exactly the change that they want it's a
powerful way to control the function of
genes in the clinic researchers are
looking into using gene editing
nucleases as therapies for example blood
cells are taken from patients with HIV
and then mixed with nucleases that are
designed to snip out the protein in
blood cells that lets the virus in it's
too early to know if that's going to
help patients but it is fair to say that
scientists are really excited about
those possibilities gene editing
nucleases have two parts one part binds
the DNA and researchers can design that
to recognize just about any sequence
they want the other part the nucleus
works like scissors that cuts the DNA
and makes what's known as a double
strand break once the DNA is cut the
cell has to repair it that repair
process either deletes the gene where
you cut it or if you put in new DNA with
the sequence you want then that new DNA
is incorporated into the genome right
now there are two types of engineered
nucleases one type is called zinc finger
nucleases and the other type is called
talons tal ENS transcription activator
like effector nucleases talents
scientists figured out how dink finger
proteins grab onto DNA in the early
1990s and then they got the idea of
attaching them to the DNA cutting
proteins but the way that zinc fingers
interact with DNA and with each other is
complicated each finger interacts with
about three nucleotides and if you don't
get all the interactions just right
finger nuclease doesn't bind very well
so these engineered nucleases can be
difficult to make just a couple years
ago researchers have found out that
there are proteins that have a new way
of binding to DNA these are called the
TEL effectors and they come from
bacteria that infect plants like rice
and bell peppers and though when you
attach these towel effectors to
nucleases they're called talons the way
the tell effectors bind DNA is that one
binding subunit contacts one nucleotide
and the subunits don't seem to interfere
with each other at all so they could be
a lot simpler to make engineered
nucleases let researchers put the
changes in exactly where they want them
even inside existing genes and there's
still some improvements that need to be
made it's not always possible to get the
exact change that you want and sometimes
the nucleases can be hard to make but
scientists are already using them and
they're excited about all the new
experiments that they can do
you